another strange question then so you've
recorded these videos
to yourself you know five years ten
years from now have you recorded a video
that's to be released once you die
well first off I am just glad that not
every one of your questions have to do
with like views or things like that it's
nice getting different questions so this
is this is good uh no seriously stuck
but it's fine because a lot of people
just be like how much money do you make
you know it's just something I just
everything's always about money now for
when people talk to me so it's nice
um but for the videos I made uh for you
guys who probably don't follow me too
closely when I had 8 000 subscribers and
I was a teenager I filmed a bunch of
videos and schedule them years in the
future and I said I'd filmed one where I
was like hi me in a year and the video
went up a year later and it was just
like hey I think you'll have a hundred
thousand subscribers and then I did one
where I was like hire me in five years I
was like Hey in five years I think
you'll have a million and then one that
hasn't come out yet but it comes out in
two years is was high me in 10 years and
I try to predict 10 years later how many
Subs I'd have that's what he's referring
to and yes there there are some that are
scheduled like 20 years in the future
and so if I don't die I'll just move
them up and I remember because I filmed
these though like seven years ago so but
uh it was I remember saying a line like
you know if I'm dead then I'm currently
just in a coffin and like whatever blah
blah because the only way the video go
up is if I'm not alive and if I'm not
alive then I won't be able to push back
the schedule upload date so go public
automatically yes and so yeah I have a
couple of those uh like if I knew I was
gonna die of like cancer or something I
had like three months to live I would
Vlog every day I'd film so many videos
and then I would just schedule upload a
video a week for like the next five
years so it's like I'm still alive and I
would completely act like I'm still
alive and everything and I think
something like that would be cool
it's I don't know why but I've fantasize
not fantasize but I've dreamed about
that a lot like I don't know if if I
only had 30 days to live what would I do
and for me I would try to make like a
decades worth of content and schedule
upload it so they automatically go
public in the future and so it's just
like I never died I'm just there
yeah it's a kind of immortality but it's
also kind of troll on the concept of
time yeah that you can die in the
physical space but persist in the
digital space I actually I recorded a
video like that because I had some
concerns and I just thought it's also a
good exercise to do a video would like
to be released if I die
and it was actually a really interesting
exercise it's cool like it shows like
what you really care about I guess it's
like writing a will but when you're
younger you don't think about that kind
of stuff but exactly mine was just dumb
yeah like I'm bones in a coffin yeah
yours is probably so serious no it's fun
actually well you realize it's like
there's no point to be serious at this
point it's a weird thing I guess you've
done this but it's a weird thing to
address the world when you the
physically you is no longer there so
like you know this would only be
released if you're no longer there
exactly that's a weird exercise you know
what's funny of all the people listening
to this yeah you know we're probably the
only two people that have made videos
for when we die it's like such a niche
thing and the fact that we're bonding
over it's kind of funny I think people
should think about doing that it's not
just about YouTube it's also social
media because think about it like
there's going to be a last tweet and the
last I don't know Facebook post their
last Instagram post
and uh
yeah I feel like there's some aspects
that's meditative to just even
considering making a post like that and
also it's a way for your the people that
love you to kind of like celebrate do
you think that would help them cope or
not like if someone randomly watching
this did film a video you know for if
they accidentally died in some freak
accident to be given to their family do
you think that would and it was like a
genuine I think it would really help I
mean it depends because like how would
you even intro that like hey Mom if
you're seeing this you know it means I'm
probably dead yeah exactly that's how
you enjoy it that's the opener oh I just
want you to know yeah I guess yeah and I
guess you could say in a kind of funny
way but um and just talk about the
things that you that mean a lot to you
because otherwise you're at the risk of
the last post you have is like like I
don't know talking [ __ ] about like
Donald's McDonald's exactly and then
you're dead that's it 100 years
I don't know this I I do recommend it
it's uh like the stoics meditate on
death every day in the same way you kind
of meditate in your death when you make
a video like that because it's actually
not just even talking to yourself it's
talking to the world and it like for
some reason at least for me they made it
very concrete that there's going to be
an end
and I'm like
it's almost it's over for me if I'm
making the video it's over for me it's
just an interesting thought experiment I
recommend people
um uh try it